but Cavanaugh has been sworn in is now
ensconced in the Supreme Court but the
left's anger over that is not even close
to ending pretty soon it'll be so bad
we'll need the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission to investigate it today on
the view to name one example a person
identified as a legal analyst called
sunny Hostin proclaimed that when it
comes to sexual assault due process
plays no role watch this after 40 years
we finally changed the law we finally
said a woman's word is enough I've taken
many cases to trial with just what every
every single woman needs to be heard
because more often than not women are
correct but sunny you are you are
insinuating that evidence doesn't matter
and as a lawyer evidence should always -
evidence you don't need corroborating
evidence you don't need a rape kit you
don't need you don't need witnesses
because oftentimes right there there are
no witnesses during rebounder show had
spent decades teaching at Harvard Law
School he knows something about due
process he's the author of the book the
case against impeaching Trump and he
joins us tonight professor thanks for
coming on so you just have a very
specific legal claim that it is now the
law in the United States that and I'm
quoting a woman's word is enough that's
it is that true technically it is true
the law was changed some years ago and I
think it was a good change that you
don't need corroboration to make a case
so that if a woman who was raped
immediately goes to the hospital gets a
rape kit identifies her assailant knew
her assailant previously certainly her
word would be enough but if it's 35
years old if her main witness said no
she wasn't there if there are
inconsistencies in the story then
obviously the testimony of the woman
though technically sufficient would not
be enough to convince any reasonable
fact-finder beyond a reasonable doubt
just think of the case today
Harvey Weinstein I consulted briefly on
one of the email issues in that case had
the main accusers accusation against him
dismissed today because evidence came
out that a detective suppressed that the
main accuser had told a friend that she
had willingly and voluntarily engaged in
oral sex with Harvey Weinstein in order
to be cast in a role having previously
sworn under oath presumably that he
forced her to have sex so women do lie
women lie for economic reasons I agree
that most women tell the truth but most
isn't enough to convict somebody you
need proof beyond a reasonable doubt
so technically sunny Hausmann is a good
lawyer is correct but practically if you
have elements that cast doubt on the
word of the woman then corroboration
certainly helps strengthen the case so
you're allowed to doubt a woman's word
that's still legal is this a sexist
elective question is it do we believe
women more than we believe men first of
all not only are you allowed but if
you're on a jury you are obliged to
presume the innocence of the defendant
which means you cannot presume that the
witness is telling the truth you have to
look at the totality of the
circumstances look we know we've seen
case after case where women have told
the truth and have been assaulted and
men have gotten away with it but we've
seen case after case where women for
their own reasons have lied the Virginia
case the the case in in this other cases
we've seen case after case and and so we
don't start with a presumption that
there's a genetically linked
characteristic we were getting pretty
you started make me a little nervous
professor thank you for clarifying that
it was i appreciate was something we
wanted clarified thank you